écoutez ci dessus du lot
amadio
pourtant les avait tous envie les
dissuader quelqu'un de vie de 25 chaînes
[Musique]
j'aime les belges d'abord je suis belge
je suis belle et je passe finalement
depuis 20 ans que j'écris des choses qui
sont ils sont absolument pas
congestionnant d'intérêt mais qui existe
depuis 20 ans je parle en tout cas si
pas de la belgique
je parle des belges ou de la flandre
j'en parle et j'en parle avec l'accent
pourquoi pas et j'en parle de manière
précise comme le comme le plat pays où
comme d'autres histoires enfin importe
il ya des gens qui qui refusent un peu
cette condition de belgique et c'est un
peu désolant mais je crois qu'il faut
assumer sa condition ou la modifier
mais la modifier ce vraiment voilà c'est
pour ça qu'il ya une série de grâce à
mon avis qui joue à ne pas être belge il
ya une dame il ya pas longtemps qu'ils
mairie m'a enfermée chez près le plus
personne ne parle avec la chambre chez
moi pourquoi vous manqués comme ça tout
le temps de nous qu'est ce que tu veux
que je dise et et et moi ça me parait
charmant cet accent la saison quand je
le dirige arrive je loue que je trouve
moins que c'est un truc charmant je
comprends pas bien je rendrai jamais
j'avais écrit j'avais créé les bonbons
l'accent bruxellois et et il ya des gens
ici qui entend qu'ils ont cru que
j'avais manqué de la chambre pas du tout
j'ai employé l'accent parce qu'il existe
bon sens ça existe c'est passé pour moi
qui l'inventé s'est vue de l'esprit et
je trouve qu'il y ait une saveur
il ya le terroir et pourquoi vous
pourquoi vous voir obligatoirement jouer
à voir vous l'accent manger de l'accent
pointu comme on dit maintenant ça fait
20 ans que je vis en france c'est
toujours logiques bon mais pourquoi
faut-il avoir ou l'accent de londres à
bruxelles où l'accent du sud non ça va
ah mais beuvron charbon soir miss
hainaut nc luis aguirre
alors je suis très heureux de
m
j'ai vu la vie sexuelle des belges un
grand moment tu fais la belle la vie des
belges de la wii compris cosmos away se
sent plus gratiné la première hors sol
et et des belges
camping là bas il buvait l'air alors la
cdas culte surtout nous elle est bien il
ya aussi de l'année photo nous la lèvre
les bêtes bière artisanale explosif on
ne trouve pas ici il ya quand même la
duvel la boisson de prédilection benoît
poelvoorde si l'arrivée patchage c'est
diable en irlande est d'usagé là je
devais recommander
il est où le garçon là où vous pouvez
appeler le financier babel tenancier aux
séries voudrez s'initiait la duvel
comment tu dis la duvel la buvette
bonsoir est-ce que je peux vendre la
duvel alors de la leffe automnaux l'alef
automnaux d'accord
ouf
voilà l'arrivée de pat masson
qui c'est celui-là
bien que ces partis m'a dit moi c'est le
dernier quarter c'est qu'il acceptait
alors le tout dernier ça s'est passé à
cannes où le jan faisait partie de
l'opération
c'est le dernier de ce qu'un du plantier
un appareil pour nous plaisait vraiment
la production cinématographique dans
toute son horreur dans toute sa
prétention sûr que j'y connais donc je
t'aime activehybrid sec et nous ne
voulions que lui à cannes c'était depuis
le départ nous voulions absolument tout
ce qu'en dit que vous l'avez alors nous
l'attendions en fait on avait appris par
des traîtres dans son entourage parce
que depuis quelques temps c'est toujours
des traîtres dans l'entourage de la
victime qui devançait on avait appris
qu'il devait déjeuner au majestic au
l'attend au lait qu'une vingtaine avec
des équipes photo caméra il ne vient pas
suite à des troubles de ce thomas quiz
des comment dès lors on organise une
véritable chasse à croûte au score comme
et on déambule à travers cannes avec nos
équipes on veut tous qu'un hologramme
on apprend le gibier localisé dans le
palais des festivals au niveau 4 il est
au salon des ambassadeurs nous montons
petit à petit des trucs gros système où
se trouvait une quarantaine on entendait
il va losc en allons les aider
et au moment où on monte toscan du
plantier lui il descend il va nous
échapper
il s'engage sur l'escalator mécanique je
m'élance à un pas du tout avant je
m'élance à sa poursuite de tarte à la
main au moment je compte l entarté en
dessous de l'escalator mécanique mais un
garde de corps m'attrape peu mais
ceinture je me dégage
souplement je suis déséquilibré je
bascule dans la vie je tombe droit parce
qu'un du plantier au milieu d'eux
d'escala tôt et nous roulons jusqu'en
bas des marches en voulait simplement
l'un à l'autre pendant la roulade jeunes
en tarte en bas des marches je me relève
et je m'écris entartons entartons et
pontifiant tout on sur ce c'est la lève
tôt nasa génial génial viens tu étais là
pour uniquement pour s'occuper de notre
protection c'est harry façon tout mêlant
art et aussi pour milan comme second est
une jeune flibustière lui en vigeur film
troisième mais il en avait partout et
macadam et l'imbécile au jeu de ce qui
était consternant c'est qu'au lieu
d'aller se débarbouiller aux toilettes
ils se dirigeaient ont totalement
inondée de centimes vers la lumière de
la croisette
il est apparu la l'eau naturellement
sous les flashs viennent pas une grosse
partie de la foule a applaudi les belges
sont leur juste blazy tu l'as fait sinon
depuis comme cet été des plus anciens
régiments d'année précédente
en fait comme avait été arraisonné par
des services d'ordre c'est
jan bucquoy mais qui ça on est occupés
et dans une jeune fille buste hier sa
vache est aussi mais oui mais bon
tabassé par les gardes du corps de
procès
deux procès deux procès gagné contre
l'état français avant parce que l'on
peut on peut emporter les nazis vous
attaquez plainte portait plainte est en
fait la justice lui a donné raison ça
deux fois puisqu'il n'a le droit
d'antenne en contrepartie les ministres
impunément
c'est génial c'est bon à savoir mais
j'ai aussi expliquer que finalement l'
entartage était une vie tradition belge
depuis l'acquisition même imax allait
plus loin
spiegel the great art chez breguet
s'étaient connus qu'en fait c'est un
honneur de recevoir une tare évidemment
tu as fait bvm6 jeunes alors à l'oiea
oui ça faisait longtemps que je voulais
la voir
mais justement c'est un moment de temps
par un de nos principes c'est d'attendre
que des victimes sont vraiment en
position de force
ce qui fait que très patiemment la range
de notre faim et on attendit que ppda
voilà tout à fait qu'on était bien sûr
on le savait depuis quelques cyclistes
aussi fait dans ses moindres faits et
gestes pour portables et bien c'était
pas si j'aime sur la jeune fille pour
aller chez mes cinq arrivées vont venir
nous laisser voluptueusement cas rien de
léger karine bien bien cette charge
voilà et tout de suite les jeunes filles
nous laisse après mademoiselle k reen
voulez vous aussi me lécher la main
s'est pas fait c'est pas de tout repos
voilà des avantages ferrique ce genre
d'agression tout à fait bonhomme est
inévitable on est léché les rythmes en
échec nous avons donc non les choses de
services desbuquois c'est un copain
depuis longtemps à ornans doubs but
depuis que ces rencontres il ya quelques
années on ne sait quasiment plus quitté
sa vraie lui sa vraie révolution et
rihanna
les chants le savez c'est le mot que
paraître ridicule mais j'aime beaucoup
ce mot comme aux 68 ap particules c'est
un vrai disons agitateurs de choc sur
qui on peut compter et un truc avec
l'art henrianne c'est qu'en france si tu
veux moi je suis royaliste
c'est très subversif des trois listes en
france nommé en belgique c'est au
contraire c'est le cas c'est décapité
beaudoin des subversifs anarchiste royal
c'est un mot qui très manipulés donc
je sais pas donc c'est moi qui le dit
mais moi je crois que je suis un moulage
les chouettes
oui c'est cette même femme née en moi je
suis pour la vie une transition complète
et globale et c'est sûr que ce n'est ni
les élections bon s'il xc les élections
c'est que les français pouvaient changer
la société entend qu'elle serait
interdite
oui c'est en prenant les armes on égorge
en tout les bougeoirs et en prenant leur
place qu'on change l'allemande mais avec
les théories les bouquins sur l'énergie
autre chose on changera jamais rien des
bibliothèques sont pleines de grandes
idées et qu'on joue donc parce que
j'avoue j'ai fait appel à l'insurrection
bien sûr et pour moi c'est en 2005
le fan qui remet donc j'appellerai le
bon peuple de bruxelles de me suivre
avec moncton sherman qui se trouve au
musée de l'armée ici en belgique et qui
est frère et moi une équité mandela ses
astra sera un coup de chapeau chinois
n'ont pas créé dans les sous sols quand
imachin non vraiment a lancé pendant des
années et donc vraiment le vainqueur
mais j'attends tous les bruxellois et
peut-être même les parisiennes
s'explique comment que la la
transgression soit réfugié en belgique
bon peut-être parce que nous avons pas
de une image de notre identité globale
celui en français c'est un française
avec quelqu'un de prétentieux
c'est tous les soirs comme ça je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas vraiment
bravo les gars on avait commandé cent
mille tard on s'est dit c'est être
l'avis de baudouin fin du gharb sais pas
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
[Rires]
nous devrons amusé ben-ari les nouveaux
alors bon c'est pas un roe a bien sûr
puisqu'il tremblay y roule en moto donc
c'est baudoin à baudoin c'était le
dernier roi puisqu'il avait y avait 40
ans de brouille baissait pas on pouvait
pas l'imaginer baiser et donc c'était
une espèce de ça d'ailleurs je compte
bientôt des taris son cadavre et les
caisses quand tu l'avais décapité son
buste avait été arrêté ça a été dur pour
toi ça a été dur puisque en fait les
rois sont des images sur sept lycées des
icônes des images dans lesquelles on
peut projeter tous nos désirs toutes nos
appels au père éternel si tu veux et dès
qu'on abîme l'image et c'est comme si en
abyme est bien sûr le roi puisque le
voilà devenu une image donc c'est le
sacré c'est le vrai pouvoir une maman
c'est à pouvoir sacré a été en prison
une nuit seulement puisque disons que
moi je j'emploie l'art comme une espèce
de conceptualisation de la révolution de
la taxe donc ce que je fais cet exemple
quand je vais attaquer que mon mentor
c'est un concept un chairman donc depuis
longtemps que j'expose l'api sherman
donc c'était feu puis bon il ya aussi
l'introduction de l'humour
continuellement puisque comme dit la con
l'humour a ni le surmoi qui les censeurs
soit intello c'est non mais pour revenir
à la belgique
je crois qu'on n'a pas cette prétention
des allemands des anglais donc on a une
espèce d'identité qui est quand même
fissuré qui est pas donc on peut se
moquer de nous mêmes et je crois que
c'est ça notre sort finalement
[Musique]
tous
bonjour comment
non non c'est bon les siens je sais
qu'il fait a calculé le centre de la
grand-place
parce que moi dit que la grande place 7e
centre de la belgique
alors je calcule comme ça aussi qui est
au centre de la région
voilà non d'audience mais je vous
connais vous nom de john allez on ne
refait pas vous êtes le mieux si oui
c'est ça vous êtes un monsieur qui fait
présentateur dentelle les yeux en france
ces saints noms des sources
on ne fait pas à moi vous allez tomber
de ma tête ah ben ça alors serait ce
qu'un jour je leur ai même ceux des
chavannes nom de josy raconter sa harley
arbitres c'est celle qui aime bien mon
pays garde chez toi tu es bettman a
abondé bettman dit non non non c'est non
mais qu'est ce tu fais comme mission
alors voila moi j'ai fait plein de
choses à plein choses mais aujourd'hui
justement vous êtes là vous êtes là pour
faire twizz vous êtes là pour le cinéma
pour faire touristes parce que si vous
voulez un mois j'ai pris peu à peu vous
promener ici d'en dresser l'un et vous
savez même pas quoi monsieur quand vous
êtes j'aime assez connu et c'est quand
même dangereux pour vous un jeu peut
même être vous garde du corps avant
bondi garton dix matches ont fait bonne
garde
et quand on parle de co 1 les routes
cholestérol historien du hadj en commun
de surprendre faire gardes du corps
quand même comme c'est quand même
quelqu'un très connus comme cédric et
une pin's une bonne petite bière bien
moussante ouais ça vous massa mais quand
on parle de tourisme
vous connaissez le manneken pis oui
benzema kahn prêt parce que c'est bon je
vais vous choisirez parce qu'ils ont
peiné parce que vous savez même pas quoi
j'ai appris à me dire indien que dans le
bassin doit
les mannequins pis ils poussent des
écrevisses rendez compte
alors j'ai ici mon petit matériel et on
va aller voir les déchets c'est pour moi
c'est un petit pipi les dix mois bettman
il suffit comme mission est ce que tu te
ramasses des crottes de chiens ah oui ça
sent mariton sont tombés sur celle plus
cher à 33 pour les primes de risque et à
suivre un geste que j'ai fait beaucoup
elles ont géré surveiller les machines
dans les labos matic à la scène tourne
bien c'est faux bien me tourner nombre
de grippes ça ce que j'ai pu faire aussi
s'est raconté l'artiste des feuilletons
raté oui ça c'est difficile aussi parce
que parfois ça tombe à l'heure de la
sieste
alors c'est bon c'est un petit peu
bouchés ou alors je vais décrocher les
chercheurs minou dans la corniche et m&m
sénéchas on nettoie ah oui
le problème c'est qu'après ses matelots
celui des centres on est tous c'est pas
de tout repos à la vie de super héros
l'invité super six en tant que nana
sinter klaas non
classe savez qui c'est qu'est ce qui se
passe là quoi qu'est ce qui se passe non
des doigts
[Musique]
m
on peut se donner aux siens ont fait
divers
non là je vais vous dire ça porte
bonheur quand on touche ici dès lors
vous voyez en fait un bras de fer vers
aveux et alors on voit quelle activité
qui ne sont pas restés côtoient ils ont
été des chansons qui cultive ici là et
or ici un petit chien aussi adopter un
chien dans des endroits enfin celui là
ils étaient trois
vous voulez bien sûr madame
[Musique]
voilà tu désolé on en fait kama bay
mobile qui tombait en panne juste là bas
sinon arrêté en voiture et hommage et le
remercier
j'ai vu merci au nom des jo il était
bourdy le métro à je supporte pas je
suis tellement content or for que
parfois on ne supporte même par mes
lunettes honnêtes gens alors je dis bien
la grèce appelé
un map et robin
il y avait le joint de culasse était
coincé dans les essuie-glaces sahin
c'est encore un coup de boudy nice
c
merci bettman aller
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah
tant qu'on marche un petit peu je vous
expliquez vous les étudiants vi j'ai
trouvé un truc pour les péchés regarder
ma canne à pêche un fils et une pince à
linge
alors je vais juste et la pince à linge
dans l'eau si tu vis elles vont venir
elles vont du monde et jo ça doit être
un cousin éloigné on va serrer la pince
ils vont s'imposer à ce moment-là grave
une petite piste magique d'opa c'est
génial
vous voyez aussi que si patty méchant
j'ai mis un petit peu et de caoutchouc
pour leur faire trop mal pour hadja les
bouffer
attention à ces magnifiques en fait un
avec la chanson zizi de pierre perret le
manneken pis elle saisit le pcn remonte
et les photographes vif des milliers de
fois par jour par déjà points de la part
des chinois des russes et américains
dans le monde entier on le connaît c'est
vous et moi
vous serez pas déçus parce qu'on
s'attend souvent voir grand ouais
leopard mais voilà on est tout petit
laid patrick qu'est ce qui est petit le
zizi du malawi
voilà une chose comment se cacher ici on
va y aller
vas-y batman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gars des cichlidés hollande mais en
face c'était il ya des siècles à caen
bruxelles était sous la révolution
espagnole y avait des espèces de
terroriste puisque thierry pocquet un
espèce de terroristes qui avaient mis
une bombe en dessous de l'hôtel de ville
de bruxelles et alors ce jour là je
demande un petit gamin un moment
quelques miliciens étaient sortis en
cachette de la maison et quand il avait
la bombe
il fallait sans cesse il a fait il a
pissé dessus voilà il a fait son petit
pipi sous la mèche ces dates de sa voix
là et alors quand mes parents qui
cherchent et les gosses aient perdu mais
ils ont dit la maquette pis et voilà
voilà voilà pour l'instant
voila voila je sens
un peu de silence le taxi oulala je sens
je sens mon mon téléphone vibrante qui
résonne dans mes hanches ou se détruit
un appel priorité les corps mais
nerveuse et moi ici au nom de
elle est mon écouteurs quoi
mon job j'arrive de suite ma demoiselle
s'est vite qu'ils vendent ils paieraient
qui est un vieux sortie qu'il a
séquestrée téléphonique de l'avenue du
départ but shakur tout de suite ça c'est
de nouveau un coup de beaune et max
d'audience j'ai 28 ans
[Musique]
nous avons alors
je fais bien les bosses et moi
je me sens bien et toi ça va très bien
tu penses des fois qu'on était quand tu
étais teenagers à ostende que d'écouter
les kincks écouter les moules et les
small fait ici
il y avait les modes c'est tout ça tu
tueras ce sont des leurres sinois tu
regrettes ça
[Musique]
ce sont mes racines poste maintenant on
vit dans une autre époque parce que j'ai
pas le maintenant des années 60 91 ans
49 toi comment tu sais ça un mois ci une
enfant
moi j'étais très intégré en mai 49 toi
moi je suis né en janvier 80 et notre
époque quand on avait 16 ans c'était là
c'était l'époque des kings day one
précise de tout ça c'était quand même
une époque quelque chose mais je peux
dire quelque chose qu'on peut pas au
printemps à otago que tu es comme ça va
je te jure j'ai des jeux sur des bonbons
quant aux reflets chinois chez les
chinois on est des buffles tout si c'est
bon on sait que c'est une intrigue qui
est très fort et dis moi c'est quoi un
film que tu as fait avec moi j'ai bu un
coup etienne du poids tout à l'heure le
film camping cosmos pas c'est quoi
l'histoire alors tu fais le rôle d'un
homosexuel dans ce film mais j'ai pas vu
le fais pas tu vas pas vu c'est quoi
l'histoire
[Musique]
j'ai fait ce film c'est le premier film
que j'ai fait sans signaler
et j'ai pas le sérieux ne s'est pas
relevé
leur demander de jouer un homosexuel jeu
comment tu sais quand on est homosexuel
tu fais quoi tu fais pas la femme j'ai
fait quoi vont faire mais moi c'est que
voilà un
c'est comme d'habitude ouais
[Musique]
oui parce qu'on peut pas prendre que je
suis sûr que tu fais le renouveau
sexuelle mais tu es dit que comme
maintenant voiture j'ai fait qu'on me
laisse b
ouais
tu connais l'archiduc ouais c'est bien
je suis vient de là parce qu'il ya n'est
ni gauzère le multi monde et qu'il veut
ce jour là qui vont là ouais c'est loin
d'ici c'est 200 m
en français ça fait combien et à la
française ça veut dire quoi ton album il
s'appelle à la française c'est pas en
français c'est à la française ça veut
dire quoi ça
parce que je suis pas en francophonie
et quand
je peux pas dire que je suis influencé
que je chante en français je chante à la
france
c'est une façon de prononcer les mots
c'est une façon de c'est un phrasé
différents à la française
[Musique]
je dois expliquer c'est parce que non
soit le temps
bon comme ça parce que c'est vrai que
c'est bizarre comme expression
[Musique]
parce que les coups quand je fais des
chansons
[Musique]
quand je fais des chansons j'ai fait des
chansons comme et quand j'écris je
expliquons que je parle et qu'on c'est
en anglais ou en flamand bonnes au
moment où enfin c'est je croise mes mots
et je peux pas écrire congrès vous
conférer au commun à brassens ou comme
boris vian peut-être borie science est
déjà papa parce que lui c'est un mec qui
écrit des chansons à la pop art kong
comme un ovono steiner pas et des autres
mecs dans les années enfin
et moi août
tu quand je parlais sait déjà
c'est bizarre même pourquoi quand je
m'écoute un jeu qu'annuaire tu vaut
mieux qu'une pire toujours plein c'est
peu celle qui se baissent coupat était
peu tout seul
j'te demi
[Musique]
au fait
jack
[Musique]
et on
wolf eyes si steve marriott démo vous
demande ces mariages
tu sais pas cela non non c'est les
brûler ce mec avant dans son
à la maison chez lui
je ne
ah bon je sais pas ça non il est des
mots depuis trois ans c'est là
c'est pas que je t'aime non mais ça me
rend très triste de savoir que ce soit
ici c'était elle
à
dispute
qt
you must smile hockey if you have
problème au genou gauche le problème oui
dit non problème
[ __ ] [ __ ] on est tous des européens
paris
[Musique]
on ça va les filles ça va jan
ça va très bien donc cherché avec
chercher arnaud qu'elle épices et
lahmada vip sait attendre et voir ce
qu'il fait je vérifie tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vim
[Musique]
est ce que tu dis
en juin
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
j'aime
qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je joue
avant
mais
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
non
ce
vivalis
dimanche
il dit
le comptoir
là ce sont les vestiaires enfin chacun
son petit cahier allée des vestiaires à
l'entrée oui oui on n'est pas obligé
tbilissi recteur amelia une piscine
ah oui c'est magnifique c'est beau et
pas très grande et très chaude mais en
fait ici tout est fait pour se sentir
comme chez soi pour être à l'aise crois
là c'est bien une cour intérieure qui
est comblée en eau et à chaque étage
c'est des petits lits arrivé petit oui
il ya des pièces fermées avec juste des
des orifices
c'est la piste de danse la salle bach
qui a une pièce où on peut manger il ya
des buffets mois généralement ils en
arrivent comme c'est assez convivial on
arrive tout le monde rend un peu pour
manger parler et faire connaissance
voilà il ya vu fait un énorme buffet ça
bouge tout le temps c'est très mal
organisé du noir
[Musique]
et on y va comment bâtir une règle de
base pour pouvoir monter l étage il faut
se mettre complètement à temps normal
quand les gens
et donc les personnes qui ont envie de
venir voir sans se mettre à l'aise
pourrait pas ils seraient obligés de
rester ici mais énormément de choses qui
se passent déjà au rez-de-chaussée voilà
au fur et à mesure de la soirée aux
environs de 11h 11h30
les gens commencent à s'échauffer et
montent petit anneau remuant se monte et
les gens même temps il ya toujours un
premier couple qui monde
c'est la deuxième c'est extraordinaire
douch ayant comme les quinzaine d'heures
pour se déshabiller
j'ai beaucoup de monde we come again une
vingtaine de couples mais ça arrive
quand même c'est bien ces histoires de
petits que nietzsche comme ça des
prairies ça permet ça permet de regarder
sans accéder à ses fantasmes conçoit
voyeurisme et sionisme qui allait
devenir il sera montré et là il n'ya
rien mais ce sont des appartements qui
donne la des appartements c'est à dire
des gens qui habitent là maintenant il
ya les six appartements
ça doit coûter une fortune d'habiter ici
c'est génial d'habiter bien mais ils
vont récupérer l'appartement ici au
premier il est rare
un jacuzzi sauna et agro et faire un
grand restaurant alors ça c'est la pièce
à fantasmes c'est à dire que par ici
l'intérieur les gens rentrent alors il
ya des amitiés ça nous agace
il ya des orifices pour remettre son
voeu il faut remettre ce qu'on veut oui
mais voilà il ya des petits trous qui
trouve à laquelle on peut soit être
gardés soit de passer ce qu'on veut ici
c'est pareil il ya généralement autant
de couples à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur
c'est vraiment l'endroit on peut avoir
son fantasme à la carte en fait pour
voyeurs et exhibitionnistes ou qu'on
aime avoir des relations échangiste mais
trois ou salade vent et même ballon sort
pour ceux qui veulent retomber en
enfance
lorelei une petite pièce un petit salon
ce qui advient d'argent de carlo n'est
jamais allé c'est que tout est permis
rien est obligatoire ici c'est l'endroit
des pervers c'est vrai que nico pour
tous ceux qui ont raté leur vocation de
médecin
vous avez commencé comment on fait on a
commencé à la maison on a commencé à
avoir des relations à trois avec des
copines qui veulent par tous les deux et
ensuite une fille qui est oui lemieux
qui venaient se rajouter souvent des
amies abby les amis assez libéré ou du
moins qu'ils avaient envie de se libérer
et puis que départ ça ne connaissaient
pas leurs capacités et puis d'un coup il
a fallu mettre les tracés par c'est une
fille qui est venu chez vous
régulièrement c'est ça ouais mais toutes
étaient testées mais ça finalement
ben oui je me doutais pas du tout au
début mon a fait par les jeunes qui
n'osent pas parler non pas vraiment mais
c'était pas dans mes fantasmes je
m'étais jamais posé la question de voir
si ça me plairait ou pas et finalement
ça m'a beaucoup plu et donc vous avez
vécu comme ça tous les trois avec ce que
je ne suis pas on a une relation pendant
un mois mois et demi et puis levier tous
les trois ans vivait chez vous non pas
par son métier au lit tous les trois oui
et puis on a eu d'autres copines qui
sont venus plus épisodiquement
ouais il a pour le moment une copine qui
revient régulièrement au 6 mai devient
ici aussi
ouais vous fait pas peur car vous n'avez
pas peur un moment de swap un peu
commune d'auch pour il faut chaque fois
des doses plus importante
non
en fait c'est vrai qu'il ya une
surenchère à chaque fois dans les
fantasmes et dans les décès mais ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui nous
contraint c'est quelque chose qui nous
fait avancer en fait c'est un peu comme
un jeu vidéo interactif dans lequel y
aurait les petits tiroirs et des petites
clés et chaque fois qu'on ouvre un
tiroir à fantasmes
on a une petite clé qui nous permet
d'ouvrir d'autres tiroirs et d'avancer
dans les chemins qui permet de jouer de
plus en plus en fait d'empêcher la
monotonie csa on appelle ça on a peur de
l'arrivée à 40 50 en 10 ans on est un
jeune groupe sont bel et bien à tant
d'autres par contre ici on assiste dans
un endroit là à des vieux couple qui ont
encore une vitalité sexuelle qui ont 50
60 ans et qui s'amusent comme des petits
fous comme ça c'est assez marrant mais
j'en voudrais vraiment pas d'idée est la
vôtre
tiens tu t'appelles d'europe nouria la
série fabrice
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
mais
ouais avec des veillées
il a au moins
casio ex m winch et myspace youtube de
l'air et des eaux
ça sonne mieux
[Musique]
c
et
la vie est un carnaval tellement de
tennis ans va où le tournant et la save
demande
entre temps tous un déguisement un
masque dans tout mon coeur fait mentir
notre réseau notre coeur et nous ne nous
montrons jamais à nous et nous restons
toujours des inconnus on en dise yeux
mois de baisse avec mes demoiselles
comment partent le matin le texte avait
pour nom bizarre dans la semaine donnée
monsieur essor cette vibration carnaval
[Musique]
pas mal
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
c
ah ah
je
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars du tube abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu